nous sommes en 2021 et je fais une
nouvelle vidéo sur ma chaîne youtube moi
même je répète oui j'ai un nouveau décor
bon en fait c'est mon nouveau bureau
pour je suis très content est ce que
c'est la peine que je fasse une vidéo
spéciale pour vous en parler en détail
non je pense que j'aurais pas grand
chose à dire bonjour voici mon nouveau
bureau
[Musique]
voilà c'est ce que j'aime bien c'est que
l'on peut changer la couleur
[Musique]
alors j'ai vu ce coup de game j'aurais
aimé avoir un avis un peu original et
vous dire que j'ai pas aimé et tout mais
non comme quasiment tout le monde j'ai
adoré cette série géniale [ __ ] j'ai
beaucoup aimé parce que je trouve que
cette série elle remet en question la
nature humaine très immoral très cruel
et pas mal de réfléchir et si vous
connaissez pas du tout en gros plus
grossièrement c'est un mélange de hunger
games battle royale et dora
l'exploratrice
j'ai besoin de ton aide alors attention
je vais pas spoiler mais je vais parler
de la série donc ouais j'espère oui oui
de toute façon depuis sa sortie de
squeeze elle m'a littéralement inondé
les réseaux c'est en se collant jamais
vu de ma vie autant de même sur un
unique sujet à tel point que si t'as
jamais vu la série en fait t'as vu la
série 1 il ya tout et à tous les jeux
les acteurs les ventes des vans blanche
de la série ont augmenté de 7 mille huit
cent pour cent j'ai pas vu le chiffre
des ventes des colorations rouge mais là
je pense que ça va être monstrueux cet
effort c'est que dans l'actualité ces
derniers temps elle a presque remplacé
eric zemmour le problème dans ce quick
games et qu'ils n'ont pas déprimant
français ont clairement cette série est
un phénomène je parie que dans peu de
temps avant le droit tous les produits
dérivés scouts game les menus mcdo avec
le dessert en parapluies les escape game
inspiré de la série le costume
d'halloween le cocktail le jeu de
plateau les prénoms des bébés aux 145
russie pleure pas pleurer comme ça c'est
pas bien c'est mieux de pas pleurer sans
compter tous les youtuber qui vont faire
une vidéo sur celui de vieilles mais
juste
il ya déjà le jeu qui cartonne et dans
la vraie vie des gens qui reprennent le
1 2 3 soleil mais version paint ball ce
qui est un peu moins violent mais quand
même un peu violent
[Musique]
aux philippines ils ont carrément mis la
poupée géante de la série sur un passage
piéton et elle réagit quand les gens
passent au rouge mouais je sais pas si
c'est une si bonne idée ça je vais y
aller
est ce qu'il vous faut c'est qu'on veut
tous et si ce truc du sucre là
uniquement parce qu'on a vu dans la
série franchement s'il ya un mois
m'avait dit mec tu passes à la maison on
fait des petits parapluies en sucre on
gratte avec une aiguille si ça casse on
a perdu tandis quoi on n'est pas d'où
déjà non supprimée numéro
alors qu'aujourd'hui un pote me propose
ça on est direct chez lui en train de
faire la laiterie york notre ayant tu as
très violent cette série on dirait qu'il
revend des trucs tout simples
complètement style et rien que les
costumes des gardes là franchement tu
prends un dératiseur tu lui en rose tu
lui mets un masque de scream et un logo
playstation et ça pue ou alors tu prends
le costume de la casa del papel tuchan
juste brasc et c'est réglé oh ça va un
peu pas titille un peu là si un petit
peu là si un peu là haut on peut
titiller un petit peu là haut et en faut
arrêter cette histoire de logo
playstation sur les masques des gardes
les gars c'est juste des formes ultra
connus en fait vous croyez vraiment dans
la saison 2 il ya un mec qui va arriver
jean riou les gars on vous a bien eus
c'était une pub est
5ème nous aussi on fait des jeux un sens
à vous dire on joue à allauch copé ont
là me fait dans les séries un peu
classique il ya toujours quelques
personnages qui meurt et dans celle ci
est le dix dès la bande annonce et le
restera qu'un ou qu'une donc un petit
conseil ne faut pas trop s'attacher aux
personnages tu vas être déçu j'aime trop
ce personnage à la vitre après j'aime
bien elle aussi
le flingue
sinon j'aime bien à lui aussi
tu pas crade et friends plus tôt moi
j'aime bien quand les personnages et son
tout petit peu vivent ta gueule
alors les personnages parlons-en déjà
mon préféré c'est lui je trouve qu'il
est un peu trop ce côté tout d'abord il
ya une âme pour l'accent je vais faire
ce que je peux le joueur numéro un alors
lui c'est le chouchou des gens qui
d'ailleurs a donné naissance à la même
qui marche avec à peu près toutes les
phrases du monde mois le lundi matin moi
quand il ya plus de knacki moi quand je
suis l'acteur de squid game j'adore ce
personnage qui est jouée par pau est en
dessous c'est un acteur de 78 ans qui
est vraiment super touchant et quand
j'ai commencé à regarder la série justin
j'espère qu'il va pas mourir lui par le
personnage dans le lecteur il ya aussi
john deere dessous le personnage numéro
101 alors lui c'est celui qu'on appelle
souvent le méchant et quand tu vois ses
photos dans la vraie vie pas plus hormis
d'appeler le tout le pizou 9 ans le
petit chat on envie de lui faire un
bisou là mais deux la joueuse 67 et un
personnage emblématique de la série
d'ailleurs l'actrice zhou yan a gagné 15
millions d'abonnés d'un coup sur
instagram depuis la sortie de la série
elle a dû se dire j bien fait de faire
ce rôle mois surtout qu'en plus c'est
son premier rôle de toute sa vie donc
chapeau après il ya tout sans que vaut
le personnage numéro 2 118
pour lui c'est un peu l'intello de la
bande il est malin mais pas très sympa
tu es se garent en cours à côté de toi
genre ouais je suis assez fort way par
entité copie je vais le dire
et bien sûr et le personnage numéro 456
joué par lee john g le personnage
principal qui eux aussi ont préféré
c'est un personnage ultra gentil je le
valide à 100% d'ailleurs à la sortie de
la série l'agent ce qui représente
l'acteur a bondi en bourse de 70% et pas
de vannes c'est juste une info
conclusion même si cette vidéo n'est pas
sponsorisé malheureusement j'ai adoré
scrute km je trouve que la série pose
des questions forte sur la nature
humaine sur la lutte des classes sur
jusqu'où on serait capable d'aller pour
de l'argent en particulier si on dans le
besoin et puis ce genre de jeux hardcore
suivi par les vieilles pies de la série
ça raconte quelque chose sur le
divertissement dans lequel on va à notre
époque même si on n'arrivera jamais à ce
level évidemment j'espère je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin de pousser le
divertissement à un niveau extrême
quand on regarde du contenu même sur
youtube on a besoin d'avoir du
spectaculaire incroyable à mr beast avec
des millions de dollars du danger et des
larmes des explosions pour être un tout
petit peu diverti probablement parce
qu'on consomme tellement de contenu
incroyable au quotidien ça qu'on veut
toujours plus comme d'hab c'est sûr
qu'après avoir vu un contenu
spectaculaire qui produit de
l'adrénaline au max c'est dur
d'enchaîner sur un petit sujet tout
simple alors les moulins à vent
bon après les moulins à vent mais
marrant street games pas non plus le
sujet le plus ouf mais vous avez compris
l'idée est une vraie question que je me
pose ça continue plus tard nos enfants
ils vont jouer à quoi pour avoir le
sentiment d'être diverti
soit ma louloute
ton manteau tu vas attraper une
bronchite c'était pas bien des dates est
temps maintenant que cette vidéo terminé
j'ai retourné à m d'individus matures je
retourne à mes responsabilités et je
vais tester le truc du sucre est gâchée
obligé à côté j'ai pas envie de le faire
parce que tout le monde l'a fait c'est
tellement random et en même temps je
veux pas quitter cette vidéo sans avoir
testé le truc du sucre sinon ouais cette
vidéo prend une toute nouvelle tournure
bah oui des amis le tuto qu'on va faire
c'est donc
un
d'agonac ndi nous allons procéder par
ordre
chronologique dans une casserole versez
le sucre combien eh ben ça c'était une
très bonne question qui me pose je crois
que toi et moi en vidant le feeling oui
bien sûr
on a mis beaucoup moins que - ouais ou
alors ils se marchent dessus comme ça
compense un tout petit peu
pas mal me carbonneau donc là on en met
comme ça
enfin les maîtres la levure après la
cuisson ces braves au bois voilà qui moi
j'en ai strictement plus rien à [ __ ]
en salle c'est déjà un succès ce week
end et la can be
en tout cas c'est la grosse éclata je
crois le carbonate infinie je vais
préparer les aiguilles ni nos premiers
tests je suis pas très satisfait
les gars notre premier essai est
clairement foire et on va recommencer et
ses numéros 2 allée attendait que ça
fonde et remue et voilà
mais dépêchez-vous ça durcit très vite à
dire si ça bouge de là foi aplatir un
petit peu je crois au là le mec qui fait
des crêpes
attends attends on n'a pas perdu sa
magie crainte ans et pas puni après on
le retourne et tant qu'on a le bon goût
hélas il était tellement beau et luisant
atteindra 3 les gars je montre quand
même l'évolution parce qu'il ya eu plein
les bras si c'est lui on est quand même
parti de serre la base c'est à dire
clairement une merde maintenant prend la
petite boîte pour faire style comment la
série
c'est dans la série eh bien je ne serai
pas mort non pas parce que je sais ce
qu'elle vend toujours qu'il est
mangeable autres qu'alimentaires à tapas
goûter suivra
ça c'est toi le booking leur tête les
gars avec qui vous voulez vous dire
merci nos châteaux non j'ai pris un
plaisir
insoupçonnées oui bonne chose si tu sais
ce mot c'est qu'il était vraiment partir
chercher à avoir adapté à la
circonstance c'est vrai mais moi j'ai
pris un vrai plaisir
adéquate
et j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion de
refaire ce genre de choses aller à très
très bientôt merci d'avoir sur cette
vidéo un peu chelou et on se revoit
quand vous roulez en fait il a mangé
des galas
[Musique]